we're back louder with credit thrilled
to have this next guest in because I
grew up on the guy I'm gonna geek out a
little bit the one and only Dean Cain is
with us Dean thank you for coming in sir
Steve I think you've this in a
roundabout way just said I'm old well
not in a roundabout way yeah I figure
it's okay because for those who are
listening terrestrially we're doing this
actual video cash you can listen to it
lighter with credit com you look good so
it doesn't matter if I'll take that yeah
yeah sometimes betrays me a little bit
but but I'm hanging in there well you
know it's funny there was so many
Hollywood actors let themselves go
completely so before we get into
obviously why you're in the news what
why haven't you like why am I not seeing
you know the double chins of I don't
want to name names cuz they could be
friends but you know what I'm hey you
know what happens to everybody sometimes
body type might be part of it stress
lack of working out hitting the drugs I
don't do drugs you know so I'm okay in
that spot who knows who knows what it is
but I got good genes and I gotta chase
my 14 year old around a lot so he keeps
me a decently in shape I'm about 15
minutes ago he was beating my tail in
the other room oh he was actually
beating you upwards you beating you in a
video game no he was literally I was
tired and he was literally pounding on
me and laughing and I was laughing too
hard to do anything about it so how dare
he I was taking I wanna get it back
well my dad you know my dad's actually
national champion Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
he's 54 and so I don't really get to do
that with him we trained together but
that's funny as we train and you're
fighting right it's full-on I don't know
if you know the sport you're full-on
firing then you get mad at each other so
you fight you're like us let's fight
about it we were just fighting it's
completely poor but now you're fighting
for real yes exactly that's exactly it
so deed you've been all over the media
funnily enough this week which is not
really why it initially reached out to
you we sort of connected last week and
then BOOM whirlwind because you were
friends with the American sniper right
right there and not only that but of
course there's been a lot there been a
lot of celebrities in the news Seth
Rogen Michael Moore talking out and you
sent Java the mole
tweet yourself what was it that you sent
to him well he said he was taught the
ciphers were cowards yeah and the
reality is I don't know anybody who's
less of a coward in the world ever that
I've ever met than Chris Kyle
so that ticked me off again Chris is a
good friend of mine he trained me
we were we were partners on stars earn
stripes we became great friends from
there and we were gonna stay friends for
ever and and I was just ticked off the
way I would be ticked off if you called
my brother a name I didn't like no I
sent back a lovely quick tweet and I
said something to the effects of call
Chris Kyle Chris Kyle a coward to my
face and I think we'll see who a coward
is it was very playground but it was
just it just came out well here's my
actually this is a genuine question okay
and believe me I am NOT going to judge
you if you answer the way that I pray to
God you do let's say it actually happens
okay some parallel universe Michael
Moore is in a room with you I don't know
he's in a bar and you just and he says
okay you know what I'm gonna go for it
I'm gonna try and in triple salchow
stick the landing
Dean Cain your friend Chris Kyle is a
coward okay would you bring him bodily
harm I mean that's the pen in the center
let's say sometimes I pull that trigger
a lot faster drinks that trigger just
gets pulled right away bang uh I mean it
would be look what I like to give him a
smack for that if he looked me in the
eye as a man and said that sure I'd love
to be on the elevator with him say that
right well with no camera wait a minute
you don't the Ray Rice not an elevator
JZ Ray Rice though right don't but us in
an elevator
put us someplace without a camera yeah
you know it's hard you don't never you
know you know when something like that
happens you don't know how you really
react I mean I would I would maybe I'd
slap him yeah I would think an open palm
and he would probably it's as hard as
anything oops
right you know the problem is though
he's so I mean I mean we've seen what
can happen when someone who is that in
that poor physical condition gets any
kind of stress applied to him you know a
slap could put him into a coma for 40
years
we don't know that was that a bad thing
wait I just yeah yeah just because I
don't want to wish him bodily harm but I
probably if he wish him bodily harm but
you know it's different to wish one
bodily harm and then cause one bodily
you sure well said I promise you this if
you were to say it's Chris Kyle you
might get a he what I got a quicker shot
than better yeah missus response would
have been probably less political than
mine was and mine wasn't very political
no you know it's funny I've obviously
I've never served and I'm very grateful
to anyone who has and I'll get comments
from people you never serve I have
served members of our military by going
overseas and entertaining the troops
that's kind of what I can do you know I
got such a nice racket as a comic by the
time I was 16 so there was no option to
not that I would have I have horrible
eyes and flat feet and I don't think I'm
a I'm not a particular physical specimen
but you know it's it's it's one of those
things that when I spent time with them
there is a certain kind of let me put it
this way nowadays or is even the
argument right do you want women on the
front lines or who should be allowed in
the military with you well we won't even
get into but I will tell you who I want
and it's what I've seen is generally
typical of most Marines I want a leather
necked loudmouth rough guy who would be
shooting something anyway only instead
of a deer you put another human being
who's a bad guy and instead of a hunting
rifle and m16 in his hand that's why I
want defending this country and you see
that with a lot of members of the
American military in specialized
divisions like snipers not necessarily
for just going into basic training
nowadays I think like eight push-ups for
some these things really pretty easy
obviously they've had to lower the level
of physical excellence for for certain
branch of the military and it's said
I've written about that but from Chris
Kyle everything I've read on the guy was
a beast it was a beast he made me look
small I have a photo of him standing
there with a Superman ass on Danny
a little bit of a opposed and I look
like his little brother in Superman
pajamas
seriously Chris was a big strong guy and
that's not necessarily what you see with
a lot of seals sure you know they don't
tend to be that big and strong he was a
big guy doing it the eye you know you
say you didn't serve I didn't serve
either but I was over in Iraq in 2005 I
was there for a long time not a forward
operating bases saw a lot of things and
and that was the way I could serve and I
still do it every day now I do all kinds
of events for our wounded you going over
there and and providing entertainment
for those guys is so incredibly valuable
and it's a way of serving and it's not
so much about serving or not serving and
everybody likes to jump on that they
didn't run me too it's it's about your
respect level for our men and women in
uniform and for what they do and and
those guys just aren't showing that kind
of respect you know they're not and that
that's what bothered for a long term how
many years have you known Chris Kyle Lee
you know American sniper
we probably about I guess there's about
two and a half years ago wait oh I said
me think let's see he was killed a year
after the show and so I met him on the
show so I guess it's mm so three years
ago three four I the time gets away from
me Steven yeah thank you oh come on stop
it just say that and then we've got like
James Woods down the block or Larry King
I saw Larry King at a cafe in LA I swear
to you he's a Jim Hanson hologram Larry
somebody I like Larry he is his head as
sharp as a tack his body maybe you know
he's been Larry for he's been like that
for about forty five years he's pickled
in his current state it's pretty amazing
guys sharp as a tack I still I still he
still does a show and I love going doing
it there are some guys though who just
you know a great example Larry King has
always looked like he's 114 yes
kind of like Bryan Cranston has always
looked like he's about 44 but now when
he doesn't look any older you know he
always looked kind of older I've always
said this about Diane Lane and I'm going
to catch like Diane Lane has always
looked like a prettier slightly older
woman and now she is a prettier slightly
older well no she was 25
pretty thirty-eight-year-old well she's
I don't think she's slightly older than
me but I don't want to be specific
she's always look pretty to me yeah some
people have you know some people get
that young Gina part Japanese maybe
that's what it is I sure hope so
and I hope I don't you know I hope I do
the Dick Clark thing I hope I look like
this till I'm 98 and then I mean I can
all just go away one day up yeah I'll go
away like that like that okay so let me
ask you something here we're talking
about Chris Cal but let me switch topics
and I do this I know this is a risk now
I I serve as an actor in stand-up comic
and no matter what I do with kids
probably your son is 14 they know the
show Arthur the cartoon I did the voice
of his best friend the brain it was a
very out of character that was a method
actor I had to learn how to pretend to
be smart and people constantly bring it
up and I have other cast members who get
really mad about that I just think it's
touched someone in a way that they they
still remember that good for them when
people bring up obviously Lois and Clark
because it's such a such an American
it's such an iconic show does it bother
you or you like I've got new stuff for
just go hey great let's sign an
autograph well you know one day Chris
Kyle showed up on the set of stars earn
stripes in a Superman s shirt right and
a little cape yeah and I whipped his ass
you know no I don't I don't try away
from that at all I'm I'm so proud to
have played that character one of the
greatest if not the greatest American
icon of all time there you have this guy
who is the most powerful guy in the
world he could be anything you want so
he could take advantage of any situation
but because he's raised with small-town
American values he doesn't and he's the
most honorable wonderful guy what else
you want you know it to be to be
associated with that no skin off my back
I'll take it this it hasn't stopped me
from working although you wouldn't know
them from some of the mean Skype
comments so you had yes because you
can't get a job well Skype no you mean
Twitter and that's type Twitter yeah
because that would only be me I'd be the
one sending you mean some people say
that stuff but you know I work a ton and
I mean I'm able to be a single father
and and be at home with my son so I
could not change
thing yeah but I that the whole Twitter
thing does oh it's amazing I mean it's
it's so quick how things devolve like
you could have anywhere in the internet
you could have someone say hey Olive
Garden has unlimited salad and
breadsticks I love olive garden's and
it's just like someone the next comment
is how they're going to hire a gang to
murder his mom because Olive Garden
sucks and it's like four comments down
quickly all-you-can-eat salad I will
tell you this though I do have a bit of
a bone to pick with you you probably
don't remember this when I was a kid and
I wasn't initially allowed to watch Lois
& Clark
because 93 I was 6 and the intro had
teri hatcher looking quite bosomy let's
be honest it wasn't me watching anything
so bosomy but there was an episode
remember this is on terrestrial idiots
we have to be careful yeah I'm making
you comfortable that's good visual there
were no visual right now okay but you in
an episode got into some farm house and
I remember yeah I was a kid obviously I
look up to Superman and you'd put a
glass down the scene opens up you're
putting a glass down I remember this
clear as day and you go oh nothing
better than a ice-cold glass of
buttermilk do you remember that I do
remember that and I had no idea what
buttermilk was I just thought it's gonna
be great like extra thick milk and I
just tasted it and it was the worst most
sour experience and I was like damn you
Dean Cain today wasn't me it was Clark
and his parents taught him that you know
cuz Superman doesn't need to eat he ate
for the pleasure of a good power from
the Sun that's the all your guys not
there to argue with me so I'm okay fun
people come in and he'll argue fun dip I
probably said something wrong and I
don't even realize it yet but that was
that an hour show however much you like
her dislike did fun dip that was our
thing that the buttermilk was was funny
and there was a thing that was from him
back at home when he was in Smallville
right and I apologize for your thank you
very much don't drink buttermilk that
was the only thing I wanted really to
get out today so and now we have to get
back to the news because it's like a
tour
let's do it so Chris grout obviously
this American sniper you've seen the
film sure okay I'll be honest I haven't
seen the film yet namely because of all
the car it's so funny when there's so
much controversy surrounding something I
feel like I have to just hit reset and
forget about that and then go in and see
it a little fresh but it's amazing not
only Michael Moore a guy like Seth Rogen
coming in and calling it essentially
equating it to German Nazi propaganda
you're obviously pretty outwardly
conservative I'm not pulling you out of
the closet here you were never in the
closet I mean it's outward about this
until more recently no it's funny i have
very liberal social views but i'm when
it comes to foreign policy and our
military and and those places and and
fiscal policy I am extremely
conservative so you would call yourself
a libertarian or do just I am much more
along the lines of a libertarian yes
okay I don't call myself really anything
yeah I vote I have voted Democratic
before how dare you not for a while you
were old enough to vote good lord no I
voted in my first election was the
Canadian Prime Minister I'm dual citizen
there you go I used to know what a
Trudeau a nut you know my buddy Turner
Oh Mike Turner and his I believe his
father was the PM for a little while you
do with a bit of an ass I can't comment
on on Canadian politics but yeah I voted
for Bill Clinton so I really will go
with the with a candidate or you know
maybe I got older in and and wised up I
don't know okay so you voted last year
you voted for Bill Clinton does that
mean please don't tell me you'd go
Hillary if she's the UH there's a once
that Benghazi thing happened there was
no way I wasn't gonna go Hillary anyway
I met her she was very nice to me and
but that that's not I would not vote
Hillary that's not gonna happen no I
yeah it's one of those things it's so
funny as she was though isn't it amazing
though right you work in this industry
in Hollywood how the Clintons were just
their golden family and how quickly they
threw Hillary under the bus for Barack
Obama
well the politics are ugly and the more
time I spend around politics the more I
see
the uglier it becomes and I realize that
it's you know there's been a lot of
talking why don't you run for office and
sure I might someday when I had nothing
left to lose right but but I don't like
is I don't like you know he's a twenty
three term congressman somebody like
that's you shouldn't do that it should
be a part-time job right I also don't
like to see these guys get rich in
office I just it doesn't it doesn't jibe
with the whole you know this is a this
are cost yet happens on both the right
in the left two and four yeah it happens
I mean I hate to say this cuz the guy's
been trying to get on the show but Newt
Gingrich I think he went into public
office we had these numbers he was worth
about his net worth was in the thousands
left it was like 30 million see that's a
problem happening good guy on a lot of
other issues but you look at I mean even
John McCain is a perfect example you
couldn't have more of a career
politician and a lot of people will get
mad because they're saying you should
never bring Republicans in the mix when
being critical but I can appreciate that
that you you don't label yourself but
you're not let's just be honest you know
liberals I know would want to punch
Michael Moore in the kisser
I just really took offense to that
comment and you know hey catch me at the
wrong time and say that comment it could
be a it could be a bad show it's it's
funny you know we have the right to free
speech right but there are certain
things that do warrant in the realm of
manhood a smack doesn't I'm not talking
about legally you would be wrong believe
me you would be wrong it would be right
but if you walk up to a guy and insult
his dead best friend I mean you're
walking into that one and I believe me
I'm in at the other end where I was
punched in the face by a Union thug and
people saying well you shouldn't have
protest to the Union state and that's
different but in this case son walks up
and like insults your dead friend or
dead mother you've got to expect that
and that's just a perfect example not as
to whether you should hit him or not
though I would love to see it but what
power does that's the big irony well
they know they're not gonna get hit and
that's that thing there's those
intellect you know I went to Princeton I
knew a lot of guys like that
thought they wouldn't get hit they can
say whatever they want to it maybe they
got hit you know so and there's a time
where they're you know it's not all
roses and there there's a real world out
there unfortunately for those that do
that here they don't realize that in
ninety percent of the world it's the
bully that makes the rules and someone
like them they don't have a chance
because the strong guys are just smoking
and this but here the strong guys are
Chris Kyle and guys like him and they
protect their right to say that stuff
however misguided it may be or however
misguided I may think it is and then I
respect their right but I also I you
know sometimes you want to be Gary
Cooper or Jimmy Stewart a good old sock
it's for this way if it was in a film
and I smacked him everybody you know
they'd all cheer oh they feel bad for
them like if you ever actually seen
Michael Moore it's um it's the physique
I have you know I have a we spent some
time in northern Michigan every now and
then and nowhere in Michigan okay there
you go but you you got out pretty
quickly right I was three yeah you were
three Western Michigan yeah actually
northern Michigan in the summer is I
would argue more urges yeah and Michael
Moore is up there the Traverse City took
a tax credit by the way to restore a
theater and that didn't pay as one
percent taxes but people would feel bad
for Michael Moore only because you know
you'd be seen as more classically studly
and it's it's the physique of a man
who's never done a push-up
so people inherently feel bad for him
because he's this underdog even though
he's an ass that's where the slap that's
right I mean I just can't I it's one of
those things I can't get past it and I
know everyone you know you get on the
the cable news and they want the sort of
righteous indignation and I can kind of
sense now that when you look at it
you're like man it's pretty silly to
think but it's if the Internet breeds
this and it is the perfect breeding
ground for someone like Michael Moore
he's a guy who probably has 20 different
anonymous screen names telling the kid
he wants to kill him for the Olive
Garden
yeah probably and that's really scary
because sometimes I'll see a tweet or
something or someone says something
really awful to me so I'll click on
their profile they've got you know three
tweets and four followers and the three
tweets were mean things about me and hmm
that's interesting timing I don't know
but you're so lovable exactly who hates
team cake apparently some of these guys
like I expect it I wade into it I mean
I'm a bit of a jerk like with that I get
it I'm pretty bold but you're Superman I
don't get why people would be so angry
with you but you know what I don't take
my comments back maybe they're a little
quick and a little rash and I said to
Seth you know apparently he's walked his
comments way back and I said to him why
it was you know I liked your movies
right now I want to kick your ass and I
would say that's it my buddies ready but
and I didn't say I'm going to kick your
ass no I usually don't do it pretty much
don't tell them I'm gonna kick their ass
I just kick their ass right but yeah so
so he walked it back and that's good and
that's fine although that was a stupid
thing to say at the wrong time he knew
it I think he was trying to be snide and
a little snip he stole it - actually
that comment was stolen from a commenter
I think on reddit they found it was just
copy pasted and he claimed it as his own
and it happens a lot in the comedy
community I have I've had friends who've
done it
speaking of which though we have to go
mr. Kane I know I well you know we could
keep you for another second if I want to
but I think your son wants you to go
back where can people find you on
twitter by the way at real Dean Cain and
your flame me at least have more than
one follower okay yes I'll be sure to
tell people to follow them so that then
they can flame your ass a follow these
guys that we can watch the watch this
play out Thank You deed we appreciated
brother and love to have you back
I'd love it any Chad Imam said she's 14
she's 14 by sharia grace of allah she's
legal to be married that is Sharia by
the way oh